DANIEL GALPIN: Hello everyone.
First of all, I want to ask everyone to give me a hand to count
Excuse me, everyone here.
How many people have an engineering background?
Ok, quite a lot.
Yes, I have been thinking about it before.
Shouldn’t show me some technical slides?
Now I decided to show it to everyone.
However, I will quickly explain to those who have no engineering background here.
When I was thinking about the future of Google games
I saw all that happened at the Playtime conference.
I know that everyone is already in other speeches.
Seeing our future full of unlimited development potential
Everyone saw it
We create a variety of cool and practical tools
Our major improvements to Android Studio
Including new NDK
And the performance improvement tools we provide for game developers.
Of course, we will continue to work hard and continuously improve
Everyone saw it too.
The power of the Player Analytics tool
Also witnessed our efforts to provide you with more and more complete data
And to help you improve your interactions.
And all kinds of efforts
So when I am thinking about future development
I want to make sure
We didn't miss anything else
Unpopular information that you may not know
Let me introduce myself first.
I have been a developer for many years and I am still a gamer.
I like animated slides
Here to reiterate that Android devices have exceeded 1 billion mark
I really like this picture so I put it on.
But more importantly, most devices are mobile phones and tablets.
This is obvious
However, the future of Android is not just about mobile phones and tablets.
Also exist in the equipment we show upstairs
That's Android TV, everyone can try it out.
The reason we mentioned it here is very simple.
We build a platform and a distribution system
And we can use the same middleware
The same electronic storefront is actually used by everyone.
The technology to build games is almost
Just a little more incremental work
And integrated into a new ecosystem
So, some future trend is waving to us.
Let’s take advantage of all the current results of everyone.
Positioning what we talked about
1 billion users on another platform
Of course, we are building a huge and complete ecosystem around this aspect.
Some people here may have seen this slide.
However, the amount of content inside is amazing.
Not only can you use a TV that has already been integrated
You can also use very good set-top boxes and micro-master devices
If you haven’t used the NVIDIA set-top box yet, you can give it a try. It’s really great.
There are also integrated service boxes that have just been listed.
Including SFR, Bouygues
And LG U+ in Korea
This is really cool
So before you start talking about the future of the game
I want to explain first.
Generally speaking, at Google
There are several different teams
Developed a variety of ingenious work for game developers
How many of you are present?
I heard that Fun Propulsion Labs please raise your hand, ok?
Ok, this is a team at Google.
They are passionate about building
Various cool cross-platform game technologies
Basically, their work includes
Repeatedly improved version
Create great games
Publish game components, tools, and all resources
They do these things over and over again
Look, I used an animation effect.
They are starting like this
They created this very great library
Called LiquidFun
How many of you have heard of LiquidFun
Please raise your hand, ok?
LiquidFun is actually a
Very cool 2D particle simulation library
They want this library to be portable, efficient and practical.
What do I mean by these?
Portability means it is available almost everywhere
We have implanted it
All platforms on the market
It has been integrated into the major game SDKs
Such as GameMaker Studio and Corona SDK
Support for use on Windows and Mac systems
It has excellent performance
Because we adopt a very intelligent way
To process thousands of particles
Basically, we will look at the diameter of the particle
We put the particles into a very useful data structure
So that we can really understand
If we are this particle then we have to calculate how many other places
To calculate all these collisions
This is also a place to spend money when building particle simulation experiments.
You might say yes, it’s calculated by diameter.
Anyway, we can see these particles.
Then we simulate in order
When we simulated the 7th particle
In fact, we only focus on observing the 9th particle.
So that we can speed up the simulation
And it is very practical
Speaking of practicality
We build LiquidFun based on Box2D.
So the two can work perfectly together
If you are already using Box2D
And want to add superb particle simulation
Simulate the flow of particles around all your existing Box2D objects
You just need to integrate this library into Box2D
See the current and cool liquid effects right away
This gives game developers and designers
Provide more choices
Now, I want to play a video. This video comes from a game we built.
In fact, we used particle simulation to create two games.
As you can see in these particle simulation activities
Not only do particles interact with each other
And it also affects Box2D objects.
So when the protagonist of the game moves
In fact, it can also be driven by these small drops of water.
This is part of the entire physical simulation in the game.
To reiterate, all of its source code is available to everyone.
This is one of the results we have made.
Also our first game
The second game is called "Pie Noon"
At this time, we really started.
Some eyebrows in this regard
So we really started
Will be fragmentary
a variety of technologies that can be integrated into the game
Pinch together
The first technology we integrated into the game is
Let me show you this game first.
This may be more important
If you haven't seen this game, let me introduce it first.
This is a cool throwing cake simulation, made with 3D technology.
This gives us a real chance to understand
How are these technologies?
Play a role in the actual game?
Of course, we have introduced all of our Play Games services and other resources.
We continue to talk about this topic
So what have we done?
First of all, we want to make sure the game is small
Make sure the game is small and extremely important
Everyone knows that we now support APK files up to 100MB, yeah!
But even then, you will still want the game to be smaller.
Because the smaller the game, the higher the download volume
In this regard, WebP is really very practical.
It can process the game into very small packages and put them online.
Many people see it in the name
Have "web"
I thought this might only apply to the site.
But in fact all of these libraries are also available for mobile devices.
Through "Pie Noon," we actually show you
How to use WebP to process all source code internally
It supports lossy compression and lossless compression
Lossless alpha channel support in both cases
It will be greatly reduced
Size of files such as JPEG and PNG
Again, it’s important to make sure the game is small
So how do we do it?
We just started using the TARGA file, of course it is very big
Later, we made a lossless PNG file.
And use WebP for compression within our toolchain
So what does this look like in actual situations?
Obviously, our TARGA file is very large.
No one wants to transfer such files on mobile devices
And our PNG file is relatively small
But when we started to seriously consider WebP, we found that this is what we are looking for.
Everyone may be surprised
In fact, we did some research
We found -- if you know how many developers there are
You may be surprised to transmit all the resources through PNG files.
And the truth is
You may do the same
The actual situation is like what is displayed on the screen.
You may not be able to distinguish from the projection
Differences in quality between these documents
Believe it or not, this is PNG
This is WebP
This is a lossy WebP. This is another lossy WebP.
On this, everyone can see it.
Less details in it
If you take a closer look, you will still see some stripes.
But it is almost impossible to distinguish the differences
However, we hope to achieve perfect results
So we choose this
Almost no obvious difference
Of course, this won't make you rid of
Trouble with GPU-optimized textures
Because they are smaller
Lower fill rate
I am not saying that everyone should use WebP to handle everything.
But if you are already using PNG to convert textures
You should really consider switching to WebP.
All right
Let's talk about mathematics
What we need to do next is
Create a math library
In fact, what we have done has nothing to do with Pie Noon.
But "Pie Noon" gives us a chance
Really make the most of this math library
Many people think like this, God.
We really need a practical math library for Android
This math library is very powerful
Because it can be used for physics or geometry
And it uses the SIMD compiler inline function
this point is very important
Because using compiler inline functions
5x faster on Nexus devices
When running on a desktop device
Speed ​​is simply surprisingly fast
So, it’s streamlined, which means it doesn’t contain the place
Connaught, unlike the kitchen sink
Do those like protein folding
Or something like that doesn't make sense.
But this is very effective for the game.
For example, we use it to calculate
The arc thrown by the pie
Parabolic Pie Path
Very interesting, the first letter of these three words is P
Let’s talk about our use of FlatBuffers.
The next game developed
When we designed "VoltAir," we encountered a big problem.
That is, it takes too long to read the level.
Part of the reason is because of the system we built
Not optimized for the game
I won't tell you what we built with.
But believe me, it's really good.
So we want to make sure
When developing the next game
Can avoid such problems
First, we decided to check the Protocol Buffer.
We thought these were very good.
But for the game, they are still very bloated
We think we should be able to do better
So, we developed the technology of FlatBuffers.
I am happy to say that many people are using this technology.
Even people outside the game field
Recently Facebook posted a great post
Revealed that they are in their Android app
Using FlatBuffers
Found that the effect is great
The most remarkable thing about FlatBuffers is its high memory usage.
The code base is very small and super flexible
Many of you... you don't have to feel embarrassed about the code on the screen.
However, many people actually
Passing data into or out of the app using JSON
In fact, they store the JSON in the app.
This is really bad for a variety of reasons.
For example, one of the reasons is that it is difficult to optimize
Because of your JSON parser
I don't know if these are actually enumerations.
It must be stored as a string
So this will lead to very slow and very bloated
You will get something like this number
What does this number mean... What does this type mean?
Look at the definition to know that it is very inefficient
But because it makes people understand, it is very attractive.
What we did to FlatBuffers was very simple
We saved an architecture
We generate C++ code through this architecture
By the way, we don't just support C++.
But this is the original language we support.
Then we can create an object and turn it into a byte array
The reverse can also
Very easy to understand
So the best thing is that you can not use JSON.
Although people still like to use JSON in practice
So you can build the architecture using JSON
If you want to do this, if this doesn't confuse
Then the most amazing place
That is, you can choose to use JSON to define your architecture.
Generate CPP files, byte arrays, which will be great
Of course, this will not solve
Your other game loading issues
But compared with JSON, this is basically the case.
If you consider such a large network scale
FlatBuffers may be 400 times faster than parsing JSON
Coupled with so many network elements, JSON still looks bloated
Again, we will keep working hard
Reduce network traffic usage and make games smaller
Let the game load faster because we know it
Can increase retention rate
Yes, we are still optimizing the audio.
I won’t discuss this aspect in depth today.
However, this technology is mainly used for sound library management.
Are some very cool things that STL usually don't do.
This is the basis of our build content.
Of course, we also have an animation framework
Everything you need to build Pie Noon is readily available
In fact, we also build the effects tool
In addition to the current built in the platform
Some excellent effects tools are tools that indicate the team is developing.
We also have our own set of tools
These beautiful charts and visual effects for display
Is the masterpiece of these tools
In fact, we are building some scripts to implement these
For the Pie Noon project
These contents are all open source
The question is, what is our starting point?
Narrator (voice-over): Pass this new version
We want to show you how to make the most of it.
A unique multi-screen gaming experience you create
One of the things we do is
When we watched Android TV we said -
Narrator (voice-over): We changed the original
Fast-paced throwing cake simulation
DANIEL GALPIN: Still watching the video.
Narrator (voice-over): strategy game
You quietly plan on your phone
Then watch the specific action on the TV screen
Find "Pie Noon" on Google Play
Try playing a cross-screen game
Then check out our source code on GitHub
Learn how to use the Nearby Connections feature in your games
Wish you have a good time
DANIEL GALPIN: To help build a better Android TV experience
We launched a
a feature called Nearby Connections
It's actually part of the Play game
But it’s just part of the Play game.
With this feature, you can very easily
Use your phone as a controller
You can also walk around and find nearby TVs.
a device that can act as a potential controller
Of course, as part of the second experience
We implemented this feature in Pie Noon
So now everyone can experience it.
We also developed the Cardboard version of "Pie Noon"
This version is even more cool
I won’t introduce it here.
But it is indeed a very useful code base
It shows how to use a different set of methods
Measure users of a very simple game
So what will the future look like?
This is what we will achieve next.
Approximate effect
The resolution of this animation is very low, I was a few hours ago.
Shot with my own device
The basic situation is that everyone can see
We used an engine for Pie Noon.
In fact, we have added a fully mature 3D effect.
Skeleton animation system
Let’s take a look at this Cardboard-based game.
This game should be very cool
I don’t want to talk too much about what we will do next.
Mainly because I don't want to grab their limelight
Although it is only preliminary, it is the next trend.
Still, we are merging various technologies.
Get the most out of their effects to help you build a cooler game
Here is a series of links
You can use these links to learn about various technologies.
Again, FlatBuffers are really useful
I strongly recommend that you have a deeper understanding.
Currently, we have bound C# for it.
Also bound to Java
Really very practical
Speaking of the present, I have not really talked about the future.
Before I talk about the future, I want to say one more thing.
How many of you are aware of Firebase?
Oh! very good
It’s great.
Actually, we were last year
Acquisition of Firebase
Why do we want to acquire it?
Because Nest will use it, and it is very powerful
It is a very practical product
Can help you with all these things
Many different companies are using it
To handle real-time tasks
So what exactly is it?
First of all, as the name suggests, it is a database
But not part of the SQL data store
The interface with Json uses the RESTful API
Most importantly, it is a real-time database
So when you make a change
Updates are automatically sent to each client that is listening
It is very simple to use
A little unbelievable
After you create your Firebase instance
Just set the various values ​​in it and start using it.
So, it's great for prototyping
Even if this is not the final backend database you want to use
Even though it is for me
And it's really the ideal choice for prototyping
Another very cool thing about it is
Its two mobile SDKs support synchronization
Even users need to go through the tunnel
His data will still be sent to Firebase
If you want to play for yourself
Build a complete offline mode, then this will be very practical
Because if your game can only be played online
Many people will feel very annoyed about this.
With this product, you can do all these things
Moreover, most of these features are built in
Of course, it supports authentication
this point is very important
In addition, it also has a security model
Can give you, for example, access to some Firebase
Depending on the method of authorization
It's deployed in the cloud with the same level of convenience as the other things we host.
Its production level is very high
It supports CDN cache resources, etc.
Provides benefits associated with this while supporting one-click rollback
very useful
This is the multiplayer version of Asteroids.
This is running on two different tabs on my desktop.
Everyone can see that is used here
Again, there is no optimization for Asteroids here.
I am very sure about this.
Its effect is not the same as using a lossy network.
Lossy network?
If everyone wants to play this game
Just send a message to mmoasteroids@firebaseapp.com
Everyone in this room can play together
It supports a large number of players playing at the same time
Flicking together
You can look at the code and see how it is built.
This is built in the afternoon with Firebase.
It is very practical
In fact, I want to talk far more than these.
Because we haven't
Talking about the future, right?
Let’s talk briefly about the future.
Really very exciting
Everyone here has seen Cardboard upstairs.
But this video is made by Volvo.
Is a joint work of Volvo and Google.
It reveals the significance of having a VR platform
It is simple to the extreme
It’s easy to get, it’s too close to the people.
So, Volvo can really
Provide a Cardboard device for everyone
Let people experience XC90 immediately
The beauty of an open specification like this is that
People can really
Use any box around you
Make your own Cardboard device
Of course, we have developed a set of specifications.
So far, we have updated to Cardboard 2.0.
Cardboard 2.0 is more rugged and optically better
Especially when you have seen the latest version, you can feel these
In addition, it also uses a touch screen
Instead of using a magnet, this is a great solution
If you look at the original version, you know that the latest version is more compatible.
And the delay time is shorter
Of course, everyone knows our cooperation with View-Master.
This is already well known.
Our goal is to introduce Cardboard to a new audience.
Obviously, Google VR will be one of the protagonists of the future game.
But we have to do more than these
Because you can't just set a set of specifications for VR
We must help build content
I don't know how many of you are here.
I saw this device at the Google I/O conference, but in general
It is the result of our collaboration with GoPro
More importantly, we built very cool software on this basis.
The video just recorded with this device.
Then convert to true stereo VR video
Of course, when you make such a video,
Need to be hosted to a location
This is naturally not the case for YouTube.
YouTube 360 ​​is designed for VR video
Finally, if you develop an app
There must be a place for users to find your app.
This place is Google Play
And, we have already applied for Cardboard
Ready for marketing and promotional programs
Again, these are the results we have achieved.
With more and more people
Into the trend of VR
We will also bring more and more surprises to everyone.
Now let's talk about another direction of our main character, of course, computer vision.
How many of you are present?
Have you interacted with the upstairs Tango demo?
Ok, I know some people may have seen it.
But I can’t figure out what’s going on, what's going on in the upstairs?
Actually it is very cool stuff
Because this is an exploration of the future of computer vision
What makes me very excited is
We are recently in Denmark, Finland, France, Germany
Ireland, Italy, Norway, Sweden, Switzerland
Of course, there is also the Project Tango development kit launched in the UK.
We finally have more countries around the world
Introduced these kits, great
Basically, technology gives devices like humans
Ability to perceive the surrounding environment
The kit incorporates three basic technologies
Motion tracking, six degrees of freedom
And depth perception
So it can read the depth of the surrounding environment
This is very important for mapping 3D space and region learning.
All of these technologies combine to enable the device to rebuild everything it sees
Accurately with sufficient detail
Show the surroundings in its "inner heart"
Thus can be used for indoor navigation
And augmented reality can also be used for indoor photography and measuring distance, etc.
This has aroused the interest of many people and hopes to use it to create content.
So, what can everyone do with it?
I think this will trigger a wave of innovation.
The first benefit may be the game.
But the impact is much more than that.
Imagine you will be able to scan furniture
Then look at the possible new home to see the effect
Or used to relate to this aspect
Home improvement ads or promotions
You will also be able to quickly preview the floor or tile laying effect or other links.
Estimating the use of materials
Cost estimation, etc.
All these things are possible
Far more than just gaming apps
What does this mean? no doubt
Everyone wants their equipment to use this technology.
Ok, I have one last thing.
I do not know
How many of you have heard of the Soli project?
Ok, then I want to play a video.
Because these things are very cool
In fact, we talked about it at the Google I/O conference.
I am not going to say too much.
It’s good to play this video.
IVAN POUPYREV: My name is Ivan Poupyrev.
I work at Google
Working in the Advanced Technology and Purchasing Department
Essentially, the hand is the device
It is very precise
Extremely fast
We use it very naturally, right?
Capture the flexible movements of the human hand
Is one of my favorite things to do
How can we make this incredible ability
That is, the delicate human movements and the skillful use of human hands.
Apply to the virtual world?
We use the radio spectrum
That is, radar to track people
Radar is very versatile
Can be used to track cars, large objects, satellites and airplanes
We use radar to track the subtle movements of the human hand, that is, twitching
Then used with wearable devices
Network devices interact with other computer devices
JAIME LIEN: Our team is focused on developing radar hardware
And turn it into a conditioning sensor
The principle of radar technology
Is to transmit radio waves to the target
Radar receiver
Will intercept the energy reflected from the target
We are able to interpret so much information from a radar signal.
To benefit from the complete gesture recognition pipeline we built
Various stages of this pipeline
Designed to receive radar signals at a higher frame rate
Extract specific gesture information
PATRICK AMIHOOD: Through these strange alien remote Doppler signals
We are actually interpreting human intentions
EMRE KARAGOZLER: Compared to the camera
Radar has some unique places
For example, positioning is highly accurate
This means that the most subtle actions can be detected
CARSTEN SCHWESIG: The idea of ​​virtual tools
From our awareness
Volume knob
Controls such as solid sliders and volume sliders have specific prototypes
Imagine a button between the thumb and forefinger
This button does not actually exist.
But pressing the button is a very obvious action
While performing this action
Will produce natural physical optical feedback
Hands can be turned into virtual tools
At the same time, you can also perform actions on the virtual tool.
So if we can recognize the action
I found a very interesting
The direction of interaction with technology
IVAN POUPYREV: When we started this project
I discussed this project idea with my team.
We think, in the end, do you want to do it?
We don't know
But we have to do it because unless we really do it
Otherwise, I won’t know the result.
HAKIM RAJA: I am most proud of this project.
We have greatly improved the processing function of this electronic device itself.
Let it do the work of perception for us
IVAN POUPYREV: There is a radar
Features not found in all other technologies
That is, it can penetrate substances and can be embedded in objects.
It allows us to accurately track the action
The most exciting thing is
You can narrow the entire radar
Put it in a tiny chip
Therefore, the prospect of this technology is limitless.
It is very stable and reliable
Will not destroy anything
It does not have any moving parts
No lens
Nothing
Just a small wafer made of silicon dioxide on the motherboard
CARSTEN SCHWESIG: At this stage
We have hardware that can sense gestures
Ability to use these hardware in real-world applications
On this basis, we can study their own effects
And their effect in the product
IVAN POUPYREV: The results of our team
Often subvert my cognition
This is exactly what I expected
I am very excited
Release this product for the development community
I hope they are excited, inspired and inspired
Use it to do more cool things
DANIEL GALPIN: Ok, finally I will summarize it all.
The topics covered in the previous presentation included helping you expand your Play Games business.
The development of advanced analysis tools
How to make the most of your mobile phone
Android investment in TV, VR, and even wearable devices
Can help you take advantage of native Android tools
The technology to create better games
Open source game technology from Fun Propulsion Labs
Support for Firebase Real-Time Cloud
The future of computer vision and sensor hardware
So, the future of Google and your future
Must be closely related to the game
Thank you very much today, thank you very much
[applaud]
[music]